What if there were a six-bedroom, two-bathroom
house with a gym and a gorgeous view that cost
$150 billion? You probably won't find that on
earth but it does exist a little farther away.
The International Space Station has more
livable room than a six-bedroom house.
It also has a couple of toilets, a
workout area, and a 360-degree view.
Humanity's only permanent outpost in space is the
most expensive object ever built. NASA has called
it home for the last two decades but the managers
are planning on moving out - marking a new era
in space. Tonight, I am directing NASA to
develop a permanently manned space station
and to do it within a decade. In 1984, President
Ronald Reagan approved the construction of freedom
but because of budget constraints, it was never
built, and eventually, the vision morphed into
the ISS - the combined effort of five different
agencies representing 15 different nations.
In November 1998, the first component of
the space station launched from Baikonur,
Kazakhstan on top of a Proton rocket - the
Russian-built Zarya module wasn't alone for long.
Endeavor already traveling 575 mph. Two weeks
later, the shuttle Endeavor carried the next
module, Unity, the first American element built
by Boeing. When Zarya and Unity joined together,
that was the beginning of an engineering marvel.
Dozens of launches over many years followed,
building the station piece by piece by piece,
fitting together tens of thousands of parts.
The end result was a 109-meter-long structure the
length of an American football field. Even though
it often seems the ISS is gliding at a slow pace,
it's actually moving at a speed of 17,500 mph - so
fast that it can circle the planet every 90
minutes. As of the making of this video, 240
people have visited the large spacecraft, living
and working on what's really a giant floating
laboratory, conducting research and science
experiments that have led to many inventions.
NASA's scratch resistant helmets created
scratch resistant lenses. The rubber molding
in those helmets is found in the soles of athletic
shoes. The polymer fabric in spacesuits protects
firefighters. Technology used to track astronauts'
eyes is essential for laser eye surgery.
NASA helped develop the first computer mouse and
the list goes on. But the main reason the ISS
exists is to help humans learn about living and
working in space in order to send us even further.
In 2018, President Trump signed a directive
to focus on returning astronauts to the moon.
It's been a while since we went
there. The last time was in 1972.
NASA created the Artemis program to send the first
woman and next man to the lunar surface by 2024
using its Space Launch System which will be the
foundation for the agency's exploration beyond
Earth's orbit. It's no coincidence Washington
initially proposed ending NASA's funding for
the space station the same year it wants to go to
the moon - although funding can now be extended
for a few more years. NASA spends between $3
to $4 billion to maintain and operate the ISS
every year - money that could be used to support
other projects. Its annual budget is about 1$9
billion, although the Trump administration has
been increasing funding the last few years,
providing nearly $23 billion in 2020. Even
before President Trump came into office, the
Obama administration tried to turn more of NASA's
responsibilities over to the private sector.
And liftoff. The final liftoff of Atlantis. When
the agency retired its Shuttle program in 2011.
it decided not to build its own infrastructure
to get to the ISS but rather have its astronauts
hitch a ride with commercial companies. NASA gave
billion-dollar contracts to Boeing and SpaceX
through its Commercial CrewPprogram so they could
build their own spacecraft. Go NASA, go SpaceX,
godspeed Bob and Doug. Elon Musk's company
won the race against Boeing when it sent
two astronauts to the ISS aboard Crew Dragon in
May 2020 which I talked about in another video.
Boeing should have flown astronauts by now as
well but an uncrewed test flight in December 2019
didn't go as expected when the Starliner
spacecraft went into the wrong orbit,
so a crewed mission will have to wait until 2021.
Opening up the ISS to private companies is also
changing the way it looks. NASA gave the Texas
startup Axiom a $140 million-dollar contract to
build a segment that can be attached to the space
station in 2024 and used for commercial business
activities. When the ISS eventually retires,
that component will detach and operate freely
as a private space station. This is what
one of the main living areas looks like.
Axiom is also teaming up with SpaceX to fly three
people to the space station in 2021. The price
per seat is $55 million and one is already taken.
Hollywood is showing interest as well. Tom Cruise
could board Crew Dragon to film a movie at the
ISS. And Russia state corporation Roscosmos is set
to get back into the space tourism industry with
flights to the ISS planned in the coming years.
But private trips are out of reach for most
people nor is this the main objective of
these companies. It's a way of testing out
technology in the pursuit of greater goals.
SpaceX plans to circle the moon on a trip financed
by Japanese billionaire Yusaku Maezawa, who will
also take a group of artists with them in 2023.
They'll be traveling on Starship, a fully reusable
system currently in development. Starship will
eventually be modified so that it can land on the
moon. SpaceX is one of three companies selected
by NASA to design a lunar landing system competing
against Jeff Bezos' Blue Origin and the relative
newcomer Dynetics. This is the agency's first step
toward creating a long-term presence on the moon
with the aim of leading to an even greater goal:
Mars. NASA hopes to send humans to the red planet
in the 2030s but everything it wants to be able to
do here it must first do here. As the agency
keeps its eyes on the moon and off the ISS,
its partners appear to be doing the same. The
European Space Agency is working ever more
closely with China. In 2022, China aims to build
its own space station and fly European astronauts.
U.S. Congress banned Beijing from the ISS due
to security concerns. And America's partner
Japan is teaming up with India on a mission to
the moon in order to counter the rise of China.
While everyone's attention is turned elsewhere,
the ISS is not getting any younger. Wear and tear
on the 20-year-old structure means the end of
its life will be some time in the next decade.
Going to the graveyard involves a controlled
destructive reentry into Earth's atmosphere just
like this animation of the Russian space station
Mir deorbiting in 2001. The ISS will burn up,
break up, and vaporize into fragments, although
some parts would survive and fall into a stretch
of empty ocean in the South Pacific. The total
weight of the debris is expected to be between
53,500 to 173,000 pounds or as many as 32 Model
X's. Even when the ISS is no longer with us, it
will be remembered not only as the most expensive
man-made object ever built, not only as a triumph
of international cooperation but as a building
block toward deeper missions in space. Without the
International Space Station, a new era of space
travel would not be possible Hey guys, I'm Cindy
Pom, thanks so much for watching. So what do you
think about the ISS being opened up to commercial
activity? Let me know your thoughts, you can
leave them in the comments section below. If you
like what you saw give it a like and don't forget
to subscribe to my new channel. A big shout out
goes out to all my Patrons including my Patreon
producer Nino Gjoni. I'll see you all very soon.